je vais te dire tout ce que je sais
Je suis arrivé avec ma famille sur les rives
de la divinité fuyant le
paramilitaires
puis les guérilleros ont pris le
région et là nous nous sommes retrouvés sans électricité
sortir
ils avaient un plan si l'enfant ne peut pas
sortir de la jungle et nous ne pouvons pas
prends-le tu dois prendre en charge
de lui jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient le contraire
chez leurs enfants
parce qu'il ne peut pas sortir, il s'en fiche
dire
Ouais
le monde
Savez-vous qui est ce garçon ?
Et dis-moi, Crisanto, qu'as-tu fait de la vidéo ?
Eh bien, vous savez que cet enfant est un trésor
pour le farc
où est le visage de l'enfant
la guérilla me cherche pour me tuer
Le Venezuela en Colombie est sur le point de
tout ça à cause de celui qui le dit
mon pote c'est ta propre histoire
de 27 qu'ils lui ont donné
qui rend ces hauteurs même pas
sénateurs qui vous